hey guys it's justine and today we have
the iphone
mag safe battery charger i'm actually
very excited to test this out i've seen
a bunch of people talking about this
yes there are tons of battery chargers
and battery packs out there
but this one obviously works with the
apple ecosystem so you'll be able to
tell in the control center what the
battery life is on it i'm mostly excited
about this for
my iphone mini because this battery
obviously does not last
as long as the iphone pro max i mean
this battery honestly i don't ever even
really need to charge it until
it's time for bed so i feel like this is
kind of one of those emergency
situations to kind of always have it
with me or
to charge my mini
oh look at you here it is
do we have any instructions in here
anything that may be some fine reading
material that i may be interested in
no
[Music]
so here it is and to charge this device
you actually do need to have a lightning
cable which is
not included in the box i do wish that
you were able to charge this wirelessly
because i really only use wireless
chargers now the magsafe duo is pretty
much my go-to
but i guess i could use that charging
cable
with the magsafe duo plug this in and
then when i actually need to charge my
phone i can switch it over but now
it's time to test it out ready sticks
itself right to the back of the phone
because it's a magnet
i love magsafe so much so this is what
it looks like on the pro max
i mean it's on there like look i'm
wiggling i'm actually trying as hard as
i can to get it to come off
and it is not this is on there now this
is what it looks like on the mini phone
it's actually a perfect fit this looks
so good on the white
so this kind of feels a little bit like
the silicone cases it does have more of
kind of like a plasticy texture it
doesn't feel as
silicone ish but it does have a very
nice smooth finish of course it has the
magsafe charging logo right there
here's what it looks like in a lineup
between
the pro max and the mini it's like a
little baby
and this is another one of the magsafe
chargers so this is kind of like the
little
wired version and you know you just
go like that that's it i'm loving all of
the magsafe accessories there's so many
really great ones
so it doesn't look like this is charged
so to charge it we just plug in our
lightning
you can see we have a little light
notification there to let you know that
it's charging
i'm curious can i charge this and charge
my phone at the same time
and it looks like you can which is very
very exciting this is actually kind of
cool because i can not only charge
the battery pack but i can also charge
my phone at the same time so this is one
of my favorite features so
you can tell the battery life of your
devices that are connected so my apple
watch fully charged
my iphone is about fifty percent and if
i attach my battery pack
we can see that it is about one fourth
charge so i'm gonna need to plug that
thing in
and get it charging so you'll see the
widget change when i plug it in
and now you can see that it's charging
since this is uh
basically the first five minutes that
i've used it i think my initial
impressions are i really do like the way
that it's designed
there are a ton of third-party
accessories obviously to charge your
phones
but if you have an iphone pro max your
battery should definitely last you
throughout the day
so some days when i do get up at 5am and
i'm using my phone pretty much non-stop
throughout the day there are times that
i do want to get a little bit of a
charge
and if i am driving my phone is plugged
in so most of the time i
never really feel worried or panicked
that my phone is gonna die and like i
said for the iphone mini because battery
life on this isn't as good as the max
versions
this is such a great accessory i think
for people who do have the smaller phone
and just want to make their smaller
phone a little bit bigger
so this is apple's magsafe duo charger
i've showed you guys this before
but it honestly is really like one of my
favorite things i love that it does have
the built-in apple watch charger
and of course you have your magsafe
wireless charging over here
now this is kind of all of apple's
charging accessories that they currently
have out
you've got your regular magsafe you've
got your magsafe duo
and our new battery pack look at this
top down
hello you look great so on the apple
website it doesn't really say the size
of the battery the mac remembers the
saying
this has a 1 460 milliamp hour battery
which should roughly give you one full
charge for the 12 mini and a partial
charge for the rest of the 12 pro models
this is cool because you can obviously
use this for anything else that's cheap
wireless compatible
like your airpods or an android phone
which is pretty cool well thank you guys
so much for watching this was just a
quick little look at the new magsafe
battery pack that
apple just released i have only been
using it for
basically the amount of time that you've
been watching me film this video
but like i said my iphone 12 pro max the
battery life is so good that i never
really have that need
to charge it but this is going to be
great just to kind of have with me on
the go
just as that extra added security like
what if i need to charge my airpods what
if i need to charge my iphone because
i've been up since 3am which sometimes
happens
i don't enjoy waking up that early but
sometimes you have to do what you have
to do there's anything else you guys
would like to see me make videos of
please leave it in the comments below
and i'd love to hear what you guys think
of the magazine battery pack also don't
forget to subscribe and hit the bell so
you'll be notified when i post new
videos
it's almost tech season so you better
believe that we're going to be ramping
up
the video production here very very soon
so until then
i'll see you guys in the next one
you